foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to add date element into
the SQL tables but before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological friends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply enough now without further
Ado let's get started now you might be
having multiple questions is adding a
date is that tough and SQL tables no you
can add a date and SQL in the format of
worker or character everything but if
you want to perform analytics then using
the date format or date data type would
be more beneficial right so for the SQL
table you do have some formats to follow
so that's exactly what we are going to
discuss in this particular tutorial now
let us imagine that we're going to
create a table using the following
syntax that is create table keywords
table name which is a user defined table
name and the parameters their respected
data types and at the end let's say we
have a date element as date of joining
and for date of joining we will have the
data type as date right then let's see
the code
and you need to make sure that when you
are trying to enter the date element
into your table you need to be a little
more cautious to follow a pattern SQL
has predefined approach to store dates
which is in the format of YY here mm for
month DD for dates you need to follow
this particular way of writing your date
and if you make some minor at let's say
you add a date first then the month and
then the year then obviously SQL will
throw an error so we don't want that to
be happening so in that case let's try
to follow the approach that SQL has now
let's quickly go back to SQL workbench
and see how exactly it works so here we
are back on the SQL workbench let's run
this use database command to get access
to our database there we go now let's
see we have a freshly created database
and it doesn't have anything
right now we will add these particular
details into the data table and here you
see we are following the
year month and date approach right now
let's quickly run this command and there
you go the date has been updated into
the table let's now run the command
again now we have the dates here now
let's say we try to break the rules now
we will try the DD mm and the YY format
here right now let's try to run this
particular code once again so let's
eliminate all the previous elements
and let's consider this as a new entry
right now let's try to execute this
there you go so it will automatically
throw an error saying the date value is
incorrect you need to change it back to
the original form that is YY month and
the date
only then it will accept this particular
value
there you go
so that's how you add date to your SQL
tables and with that we have come to an
end of this session on how to add date
into your SQL tables and if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources that we used in
the session like PPT code Etc then do
let us know in the comment section below
and RTM of X Plus we'll be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at
your list until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here